Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Raumzeit, dem Podcast und Projekt der ESA und des DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und mittlerweile sind wir hier bei der siebten Ausgabe angekommen. Und nachdem wir schon so einige Reisen unternommen haben, uns mit Missionsplanung, Erdbeobachtung, Planeten, etc. auseinandergesetzt haben, müssen wir heute mal den Blick auf ein ganz anderes Thema richten, was allerdings mit allem in irgendeiner Form auch zu tun hat. Nämlich dem Problem des Weltraumschrotz oder Weltraummülls. Der Problematik, dass eben auch, wenn man Reisen unternimmt, ab und zu mal was übrig bleibt. Ja und dazu begrüße ich als Gesprächspartner Holger, Holger Krag. Dazu muss man sagen, diese Ausgabe kommt wieder einmal aus Darmstadt, vom ESOG, vom European Space Operations Center, wo wir uns jetzt befinden, wo du ja auch deinen regelmäßigen Arbeitsplatz hast.
Ja genau, so ist es.
Wie nennt man diesen Bereich, in dem du da werkelst?
Also wir sprechen, wir sprechen ganz zurückhaltend von Weltraumrückständen. Um fachlich genau zu sein wäre das der Terminus, den man verwenden sollte. Unser Büro nennt sich Büro für Raumfahrtrückstände. Und wir sind verantwortlich für Aufgaben, die mit dem Betrieb der ESA-Satelliten zu tun haben, im Zusammenhang mit Weltraumrückständen, wie zum Beispiel Ausweichmanöver, wenn immer sie notwendig werden. Wir haben aber auch damit zu tun, Vermeidungsstrategien zu planen und darauf zu achten, dass die ESA-Missionen die auch ordnungsgemäß umsetzen. Also Vermeidungsstrategie im Hinblick auf die Erzeugung von Weltraumrückständen.
Ja, wie es zu den Rückständen kommt, das sollten wir jetzt mal besprechen. Vorher würde mich noch mal interessieren, wie so dein Weg zur Raumfahrt so gewesen ist. Wie landet man da hin? Wie kommt man sozusagen zur Astromillabführ?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das beispielhaft ist, aber es ist schade sicherlich nicht, wenn man schon von Kindzeiten an ein Faible für die Raumfahrt hat. Ich kann nicht sagen, dass ich zielstrebig darauf hingearbeitet habe, aber Interesse war immer da an der Raumfahrt. Das geht zurück auf Grundschulzeiten. Vielleicht hängt es damit zusammen, dass man auch automatisch ein Interesse für naturwissenschaftliche Fächer entwickelt. Richtig klar geworden, dass ich was in dem Bereich Raumfahrtechnik mache und nicht etwa Astrophysik oder Astronomie, ist mir dann erst nach dem Abitur, sodass ich dann in die ingenieursmäßige Richtung eingeschlagen bin. Und dann relativ zielstrebig mein Studium auf die Raumfahrt ausgerichtet habe. Was für ein Studium war das? Das war ein Maschinenbaustudium mit Vertiefung Luft- und Raumfahrtechnik an der TU Braunschweig in dem Fall. Und wenn man an der TU Braunschweig studiert, dann kommt man an dem Thema Weltraumrückstände oder Weltraumschrott nicht vorbei. Denn dort gibt es ein Institut, was sich schon seit Jahren mit dem Aspekt befasst. Und auch für die ESA eine sehr wichtige Expertisefaktor ist in dem Bereich und uns auch Modelle liefert, die wir hier täglich nutzen. Ja, wenn man durch die Schule geht, dann wird man automatisch ein Raumfahrtrückstandsexperte.
Wie lange ist denn das Thema überhaupt schon auf der Agenda?
Also das Thema kam schon in den 70er Jahren auf. In den 70er Jahren, also nach 20 Jahren Raumfahrt ungefähr, hat man festgestellt, dass man ungefähr 4000 bekannte Objekte im All hat. Und da hat ein Mensch, dessen Namen inzwischen bestand, eines fachlichen Terminus geworden ist, nämlich Donald Kessler. Wir sprechen heute vom Kessler-Syndrom. Der hat sich als erstes mal Gedanken gemacht, dass wir eigentlich Raumfahrt nur in einem Bereich betreiben, ganz intensiv, der gar nicht so groß ist. Wenn wir etwa starten, dann benutzen wir vorzugsweise eigentlich nur zwei Bahnen. Das eine ist die Geostationäre-Bahn, wo unsere Nachrichtensatelliten fliegen und auch die Wettersatellitenfiele. Das andere sind Bahnen, von denen aus wir die Erde beobachten. Die sind normalerweise zwischen 600 und 1200 Kilometer. Das heißt, die Raumfahrt übertreiben ist gar nicht so weit weg von der Erde. Da beilen sich diese 4.000 Objekte, die man damals im All hatte.
Was heißt denn, man wusste, dass da 4.000 sind? Also wusste man, dass sie da noch irgendwo sein müssten? Oder wusste man auch etwa, wo sie sich wohl aufhalten?
Ja, gute Frage, denn man hätte eigentlich mit weniger Objekten gerechnet, von dem, was man gestartet hat. Man weiß ja, was man gestartet hat. Man sollte also den den Satelliten dort erwarten. Man sollte vielleicht noch eine Raketen-Oberstufe erwarten, aber sonst nichts. Jetzt gibt es aber ein Überwachungsnetzwerk. Das wird von der amerikanischen Luftwaffe betrieben. Das ist eigentlich nicht dazu da, sich die Objekte im Weltraum anzugucken, die dort ihre Bahnen ziehen, sondern im Wesentlichen anfliegende Marschflugkörper zu identifizieren. Wenn man das aber machen will, dann muss man auch ein ganz gutes Bild davon haben, was eigentlich im All um die Erde kreist. Denn nur dann kann man sicher anfliegende Ballistik-Missiles von harmloser Höhe...
Welche Höhe würden die denn normalerweise angreifen, diese Ballistik-Missiles?
Also die interkontinentalen Raketen, die haben ein ähnliches Flugprofil, wie man das von einem niedrig fliegenden Raumfahrtkörper auch erwarten könnte.
Also was das so 300 Kilometer...
Eventuell sogar noch höher. Das heißt, man musste sich in Lage machen von der Situation, die man im All hatte. Und da hat man relativ schnell gemerkt, ups, es ist ja viel mehr da oben, als wir eigentlich dachten. Und dann hat man sich intensiver angeguckt, wo das herkommt.
Wie haben Sie das gemacht? Einfach mit optische Beobachtung, Teleskope, Radar? Also wie kann man diesen Bereich denn effektiv überwachen?
Ja, beides. Also du hast schon die richtigen Mechanismen da genannt. Man benutzt Radaranlagen, um den erdnahen Bereich abzudecken. Da spricht man so bis 2000 Kilometer Höhe. Und dann Teleskope für den Bereich darüber. Denn Radaranlagen sind besonders empfindlich bei kurzen Entfernungen. Und bei Teleskopen, die kann man noch gebrauchen, wenn es weiter rausgeht. Und bei Objekten, die weiter weg sind, die befinden sich nicht allzu oft im Schatten, wie die, die dicht an der Erde sind. Und die beiden Instrumente zusammen geben uns ein ganz gutes Bild.
Verstehe. Und kombiniert das dann gegebenenfalls auch, um sich sicher zu sein.
Man muss das kombinieren, genau. Und auf die Art und Weise verfolgen die Amerikaner diese Objekte. Heute ist die Zahl auf 16.000 angewachsen. Damals waren es 4.000.
Also die 4.000 haben schon so ein bisschen Schock erzählt. Und was war denn der Grund, dass es 4.000 waren, obwohl es noch keine 4.000 Missionen gab?
Der Grund war, dass es immer wieder zu Fragmentationen gekommen ist. Das heißt, Objekte, die wir gestartet haben, sind aus verschiedenen Gründen, haben sich zerlegt. Das kann in den meisten Fällen ist der Grund, Resttreibstoffe, die an Bord sind. So eine Raketenoberstufe ist dafür ausgelegt, dass sie zehn Minuten lang funktioniert. Das ist ungefähr die Zeit, die es braucht von der Erdoberfläche in den Weltraum, in den erdnahen Weltraum. Was danach mit der Rakete passiert hat, bis dahin nie jemand interessiert. Ja, du hast recht. Es ist natürlich auch nachvollziehbar. In den frühen Tagen der Raumfahrt gingen alle Anstrengungen dahin, einen Start sicher zu gewährleisten, um zu sorgen, dass der Satellit die vorgesehene Bahn erreicht. Es ist völlig klar, dass man sich um den Prozess danach noch keine Gedanken gemacht hat. Das liegt in der Natur des Menschen. Später hat man gemerkt, dass diese Resttreibstoffe sich selbst entzünden können. Insbesondere nach Jahrzehnten, wenn Korrosionsprozesse einsetzen, wenn Mikromethoriten einschlagen, Sauerstoff und Brennstoffträger dadurch auf irgendeine Art und Weise zusammenkommen. Meistens sind die Hypergol und dann kommt es zur Selbstentzündung und dann hat man solche Effekte. Leider passiert das auch.
Das hat sich dann explodiert oder sich einfach in andere Bereiche bewegt.
Genau. Die sind explodiert im Wesentlichen. Was wir jetzt da sehen, sind die Fragmente. Das heißt, der Großteil der Objekte, die wir heute sehen, sind gar keine intakten Objekte, sondern Bruststücke von ehemals intakten Objekten. Dazu kommt ein sehr interessanter Aspekt, auch eine absichtliche Zerstörung, die insbesondere zu Zeiten des Kalten Kriegs hin und wieder stattgefunden hat. Also dass man versucht hat, für Testzwecken seinen eigenen Satelliten zu zerstören, um zum Beispiel zu probieren, ob man auf die Art und Weise eine effektive Antisatellitenwaffe erreichen kann. Das ist natürlich kontraproduktiv, wie wir es dir sicherlich vorstellen könnten.
Ja, aber es ist nicht belegt, dass sie sich jetzt gegenseitig die Satelliten weggehauen haben.
Das ist zum Glück noch nicht passiert.
Das wird auch hoffentlich nie passieren.
Es ist naheliegend, dass diese Waffen dafür entwickelt werden, aber aus Sicht eines Weltraum-Schrott-Experten macht das keinen Unterschied, ob das jetzt der gegnerische Satellit war oder der eigene, weil den Salat haben wir auf dem Tisch.
Kaputt ist kaputt. Das heißt, dieses Überwachungsnetzwerk hat dieses Thema überhaupt erst mal auf die Agenda gebracht. Man hat einfach mal geguckt, wo sind denn die feindlichen Misshalte, was man gesehen hat, war eine Trümmerwüste von 20 Jahren Raumfahrt.
Richtig, ja. So ist es. Also das ist erst mal, wie du schon gesagt hast, der erste Schock war sicherlich die Erkenntnis über das Problem. Der zweite Schock wurde dann ausgelöst durch den Herrn Kessler, der vorher gesagt hat, dass es durch diese Vielzahl von Objekten auf engen Raum auch zu Kollisionen kommen wird. Das heißt, hier trifft ein Objekt auf das andere. Und wie du sicherlich weißt, sind die Geschwindigkeiten der Objekte im All sehr hoch. So ein Objekt im erdnahen Raum muss mit ungefähr 7 km pro Sekunde. Unterwegs sein, um sich überhaupt auf seiner Bahn halten zu können. Und das ist also die Geschwindigkeit, mit dem was zu tun haben. Bei einer frontalen Kollision hat man also die doppelte Geschwindigkeit. Wir sprechen hier also von 40.000, 50.000 kmh, die bei Kollisionen auftreten. Und die Energien, die da frei werden, die führen dazu, dass die beiden kollidierenden Objekte sich komplett zerlegen, also noch mehr Trümmer erzeugen. Das hat der Herr Kessler vorher gesagt und er hat auch vorher gesagt, dass diese Trümmererzeugung, die dadurch entsteht, natürlich wieder Kandidaten liefert für neue Kollisionen, sodass also quasi so ein schleichender Kettenreaktionseffekt in Gang gesetzt wird.
Und das findet auch statt.
Ja, und da hast du recht, gerade in den letzten Jahren schält sich heraus, dass diese Effekte inzwischen tatsächlich stattfinden. Wir hatten jetzt vier Kollisionen. Seit 1991 war die erste. Man kann natürlich nur die Kollisionen zwischen den Objekten sehen, die auch von dem US-Überwachungssystem erfasst werden. Das war die erste. Dann folgte fünf Jahre später die zweite. Und jetzt haben wir so ungefähr einen Fünf-Jahres-Rhythmus, eine Kollision. Die spektakulärste war gerade letztes Jahr, 2009. Denn da war ein aktiver Satellit mit involviert. Ein Iridium-Kommunikationssatellit. Weil es davon mehr als 60 gibt, hat das die Kommunikation nicht gestört.
Weil die sind sozusagen darauf ausgelegt, dass mal auch einer ausfällt.
Ja, nicht unbedingt aus dem Grund. Aber immerhin sind sie auf Renundanz ausgelegt.
Auf welcher Höhe ist Iridium unterwegs?
860. Kilometer. 860 Kilometer war ein anderes Ereignis, was uns Kopfschmerzen macht. Im Januar 2007 ist auf dieser Höhe ein chinesischer Wetter-Satellit abgeschossen worden. Und zwar von einer vom Boden gestarteten Missile, auch aus China. Das war also wiederum so ein Antisatellitentest.
Die haben ihren eigenen Satelliten abgeschossen.
Ihren eigenen Satelliten abgeschossen. Einfach, um zu testen, ob man eine wirksame Antisatellitenwaffe vom Boden aus betreiben kann.
Falls mal einer kommt, den man nicht mag.
Ja genau. Die mögen, so wie andere Großmächte mögen dies nicht, wenn man sich ihr Land von oben anguckt. Da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten, das zu verhindern. Man kann hier mit dem Laser blenden. Oder wenn es ganz hart kommt, wenn man den Gegner richtig auswaschen will, dann muss man den Satelliten zerstören. Was man dabei nicht bedenkt, ist, dass man sich dabei selber noch viel mehr eins auswischt. Denn die Trümmerwolke, die dabei entsteht, macht keinen Unterschied zwischen der Nationalität eines Satelliten. Sie belastet alle gleichermaßen. Im Fall der Iridium-Kollision ist es besonders dramatisch. Denn alle anderen Iridium-Satelliten bewegen sich natürlich in derselben Bahnhöhe. Die sollen den gleichen Service liefern mit der gleichen Abdeckung und der gleichen Leistung. Da kannst du dir sicherlich vorstellen, dass die Konstellation, die am härtesten betroffen ist, die Iridium-Konstellation selber ist.
Gegen was ist der gegen geflogen?
Das war ein ausgedienter russischer Kommunikationssatellit, der aus den 90er Jahren stammt.
Der auch ursprünglich in dieser Höhe unterwegs war?
Der in der Höhe unterwegs war und der belassen worden ist nach seinem Betrieb, wie das leider gang und gäbe ist.
Aber sinken die dann nicht nach der Zeit auch einfach in der Höhe ab?
Ja, da hast du recht, die sinken ab. Allerdings sinken nicht alles ab, was nicht beschleunigt wird. Doch, es sinkt eigentlich alles ab, was noch so in der Reichweite der letzten Reste der Erdatmosphäre liegt. Erdatmosphäre muss man sich so vorstellen, dass sie in der Dichte exponentiell abnimmt nach oben. Das heißt, dass tiefe Bahnen, zum Beispiel die Raumstation, die in 400 km fliegt, durch relativ dichte Atmosphäre noch fliegt. Das heißt, sie prasseln die Atome Stück für Stück einzeln auf die Oberfläche und bewirken langsam eine Abrämsung. Die ist in der Höhe so stark, dass man die Raumstation immer wieder anheben muss. Und das so ein- bis zweimal pro Jahr. In der Höhe, wo diese Ereignisse passiert sind, das sind 800 km. Das ist die Atmosphäre bereits so dünn, dass es 200 Jahre braucht, bis ein Objekt vollständig abstürzt. Das sind natürlich die Höhen, wo sich dann auch die Objekte anfangen zu akkumulieren. Das ist dann nämlich auch eine Höhe, die erstmal gern benutzt wird, weil man von dort aus wunderbar die Erde beobachten kann. Und zweitens, wo die Bahnlebensdauer lang ist. Also perfekte Bedingungen für das Einsetzen dieses Kessler-Syndroms. Und das ist genau die Höhe, in der das jetzt auch stattfindet.
Und jetzt ist man bei 16.000?
Ja, 16.000, die man kennt.
Also insgesamt über alle Höhen oder betrifft das jetzt nur diese 800 Kilometer-Zone?
Also das betrifft alle Höhen. Man kann aber davon ausgehen, dass sich 80 Prozent unterhalb von 2.000 Kilometer befinden. Von diesen 16.000.
Das heißt, die geostationäre Bahn, jetzt bei 36.000 Kilometer, ist gar nicht so sehr davon betroffen?
Die ist auch betroffen. Ich meine, es ist zwar weit draußen. Das heißt, das Volumen wird größer. Das klingt so, als ob da mehr Platz wäre. Aber hier ist es so, dass dieser Effekt der Geostationalität nur funktioniert, wenn die Objekte in einer Bahnebene sind, nämlich in der Äquator-Ebene. Und das führt dazu, dass eigentlich nur exakt eine Bahnhöhe nutzbar ist. Nämlich 36.000 Kilometer ungefähr. Nur in dieser Höhe funktioniert das. Und auch nur in der gleichen Ebene. Das heißt, die Objekte sind aufgereiht wie auf einer Perlenschnur.
Am Äquator.
Am Äquator. Das heißt, von diesem ganzen großen Raum wird eigentlich nur eine einzelne Spur genutzt. Und deswegen ist auch diese 2000 Objekte, oder etwas weniger sind es, die in dem Bereich sind, die können sich fast gegenseitig angucken. So dicht sind die nebeneinander.
Aber sie haben ja alle dieselbe Geschwindigkeit.
Ja, sie fliegen alle in die gleiche Richtung. Aber hier passiert Folgendes. Wenn ein Objekt nicht mehr kontrollierbar ist, dann führen einzelne Bahnen, dann ist es letztendlich den natürlichen Kräften überlassen. Und die natürlichen Kräfte üben Bahnstörungen aus, die dazu führen, dass sich die Bahn eben neigt. Und dann überschneiden sich quasi die neue Bahn des Objektes und die Äquator-Ebene.
Das schlingern sozusagen ein bisschen um den Äquator herum.
Zwei Mal pro Tag tauchen die Objekte durch die Äquator-Ebene durch.
Was heißt natürliche Kräfte? Von welchen Kräften reden wir jetzt? Einfach nur von den Gravitationsunterschieden der Erde?
Ja, es hängt damit zusammen, dass das Erdgravitationsfeld nicht ganz kugelsymmetrisch ist. Und es hängt auch davon ab, dass Drittkörper wie Sonne und Mond die Bahn beeinflussen.
Klar, im Internet wollte ich krass sagen. Im Weltall, da reißt ja alles an allem. Im Internet natürlich auch.
Aber im Internet macht auch jeder, was er will.
Ist auch eine Menge Müll, den man mal einsammeln sollte.
Ja, also das ist die Situation, die wir heute haben. Das heißt, die Menschheit macht sich selber das Leben schwer mit der Bahnhöhe von 800 bis 1000 Kilometer und auf der Gehstationärbahn.
Wie klein sind denn... Also ich meine, da waren mal große Dinge, dann sind ein paar explodiert, ein paar andere sind irgendwie zusammengestoßen und durch dieses Kessler-Syndrom oder Kessler-Effekt kommen wir jetzt sozusagen in die Situation, alles schlingert irgendwie rum, alles prallt aufeinander. Die Teile werden immer kleiner, mehr. Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, ich weiß nicht, steigt die Wahrscheinlichkeit dann für Kollusionen vermutlich? Mathematisch kann ich das jetzt gar nicht belegen. Aber es ist sozusagen mehr los. Das heißt, alles wird immer kleiner und wird immer vielfältiger. Das ist dann gar kein Schrottplatz mehr. Das ist dann eigentlich schon eher so eine Staubwolke.
Sicherlich richtig.
Also wie klein sind diese Teile? Und ab welcher Größe sind die eigentlich ein Problem? Wenn so ein Satellit auf mich einschlägt, kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass das ein Problem ist.
Das macht Kopfschmerzen.
Aber wenn da jetzt Euro-Münzen durch die Gegend fliegen...
Also schade, dass man Podcasts nicht sehen kann. Ich hätte ein schönes Anschauungsstück. Wir haben so einen Aluminium-Block in unserem Büro, den man mit einer Aluminium-Kugel von nur 1 cm Durchmesser beschossen hat. Und die hat man beschleunigt auf 6 km pro Sekunde. Das wäre also nur die Hälfte von dem, was man so an Kollisionsgeschwindigkeiten haben könnte. Und die hat da einen 5-6 cm groß tiefen Krater reingerissen. Man kann sich vorstellen, dass so ein 1 cm groß Objekt bei der Geschwindigkeit so die Energie einer explodierenden Handgranate hat. Das heißt, es ist nichts, was man mit der Außenhaut eines Satelliten aufhalten könnte. Wir sagen so ungefähr, dass ein 1 cm Objekt, wenn es die richtige Stelle trifft, die Mission eines Satelliten beendet, auf grausame Weise. Und jetzt kommt eine folgende Problematik. Dieses Überwachungsnetzwerk sieht solche kleinen Objekte gar nicht. Diese 16.000, von denen ich gesprochen habe, das sind Objekte, die die Größe eines Fußballs haben und mehr, aber nicht kleiner. Das liegt einfach daran, dass das Netzwerk... Ja klar, alles hat eine begrenzte Empfindlichkeit. Das kann man gar nicht sehen von der Erde aus. So, da nimmt man ein Modell und schaut sich an, was würde denn so ein Modell, wenn man dem sagt, es gab bereits 250 Fragmentationsereignisse. Das ist das, was wir tatsächlich haben. Und viele andere Mechanismen, die Raumfahrtsschrott erzeugen. Wenn man das in das Modell führt und eine Vorhersage macht, was wir in dem Kleinteilbereich eigentlich an Putman-Objekten da oben haben müssen, dann kommt man zu einer Zahl von 600.000 für diese 1 cm großen Objekte.
Aha, also im Bereich von 800 bis 36.000 km fliegen 600.000 Handgranaten.
600.000 Handgranaten, ja genau. Und wenn man dann bis 1 mm geht, das sagen unsere Modelle auch, und dann kommt man in die Millionen, muss man sich bei 1 mm Objekten noch Sorgen machen? Würde man fragen, ja, man muss. Denn selbst solche kleinen Objekte allein durch die große Zahl führen mehr oder weniger natürlich bei jeder Mission, zumindestens ein Einschlag, häufig sogar mehreren. Und wenn da empfindliche Stellen getroffen werden, wie z.B. ein Sensor, ein optischer Sensor-Oberfläche oder eine Kühlleitung, dann kann es auch sehr schlecht ausgehen für eine Mission.
Hat man denn schon mal daran gedacht, einen Satelliten hochzuschicken, der einzig als Einschlagsziel dient und darauf ausgelegt ist, quasi so eine Sensorik zu haben, der sozusagen gut funktioniert, auch wenn er tausendmal perforiert wird, aber das dann auch mitkriegt und zählen kann?
Ja, also dass du das sagst, das freut mich, denn viele denken einfach an ein Objekt, was eine große Schaumstoffkugel, die Objekte einsammelt. Aber es geht tatsächlich erst mal darum, zu messen. Was kann man denn überhaupt, diese kleinen Objekte, die in die Modelle davor sagen, nachweisen?
Ja, sowieso eine große spanische Wand, die man da halt so durch die Gegend fliegen lässt.
Ja, man ist ein bisschen bescheidener. Man ist ein bisschen bescheidener. Man hat Spezialsensoren entwickelt, die so die Größe eines DIN-A4-Blocks haben und die Sensorfläche. Auf der ist so ein, wie nennen wir das, Aerogel. Das ist quasi so eine Substanz, die hart ist, aber die Einschläge aushält, ohne dabei neue Trümmer zu erzeugen. Das wäre ja nichts blöder, als wenn der Sensor zertrümmert wird. Und er schluckt die sozusagen. Er schluckt die sozusagen und registriert den Einschlag und auch die Einschlagenergie, wo man dann rückschließen kann auf die Größe.
Was kann dieses Aerogel aufnehmen? Ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal von diesem Zentimeter-Aluminium-Kügelchen ausgeht, was sechs Zentimeter in den Aluminiumblock hineinschlägt, was kann denn so ein Aerogel abfangen?
Das würde Aerogel auch nicht aushalten. Dieses Aerogel geht vielleicht bis ein Millimeter. Und die Sensorfläche ist so klein, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit ausschließt, dass man da größere Objekte mit einfängt.
Das ist das gleiche Material, was auch verwendet wird, wenn man so Kometen hinterherfliegt, um die Partikel einzusammeln?
Ich glaube ja. Es gibt verschiedene Mechanismen. Einige benutzen auch so einen Lichtzaun oder zwei Lichtzäune, womit man, wenn der Lichtstrom kurz unterbrochen wird, dann einen Einschlag registriert wird. Es gibt verschiedene Techniken. Dieses Aerogel ist das, was jetzt bereits ein-, zweimal zum Einsatz gekommen ist.
Und was hat man dabei festgestellt?
Ja, wir haben Recht. Also das ist jetzt ein bisschen plakativ, aber es gibt diese Teile und es gibt sie auch in der Zahl, wie man sie erwarten würde. Und jetzt helfen uns diese Daten, die Modelle sozusagen fein zu tunen, zu kalibrieren, anzupassen, sodass wir also tatsächlich einen Mechanismus in der Hand haben, der uns erlaubt, die Entstehung von Weltraumschrott wissenschaftlich nachzuvollziehen. Diese Daten fließen jetzt seit einer Weile. Wir benutzen nicht nur solche, sondern wir benutzen auch Messungen von der Erde, die empfindlicher sind als das, was das amerikanische Netzwerk macht. Allerdings nicht so systematisch, sondern das sind dann eher so sporadische Messungen. Die sind sehr teuer, das muss man zeitlich limitieren. Aber auch diese kurzen Einblicke in das Environment, so bis ein Zentimeter herunter, die liefern uns schon Datenmaterial. Was man auch machen kann, ab und zu kommt es ja mal vor, du kennst sicherlich das Hubble Space Teleskop und du weißt, dass es da Maintenance-Missionen gab. Space Shuttle ist schon zweimal nach dem Aussetzen dort wieder angedockt und hat verschiedene Wartungsarbeiten durchgeführt, unter anderem die Solarzellen ausgetauscht. Und die alten Solarzellen sind zurück zur Erde gebracht worden. Das ist einer der seltenen Fälle, wo man mal Space-Hardware wieder vorgesetzt bekommt, nach einigen Jahren im Weltraum.
Wie viele Jahre waren die dann draußen?
Also jeweils vier Jahre, meine ich. Und das ist schon, vor allen Dingen in einer Höhe, die schon stark belastet ist. Also Hubble ist so 560, deutlich über 500 Kilometer. Das ist auch so die äußere Grenze von dem, was der Space Shuttle überhaupt erreichen kann. Und der Space Shuttle selber hält sich da oben nicht so gerne lange auf, aufgrund der hohen Objektdichte, unter anderem. In der Raumstationhöhe sieht das ein bisschen besser aus. Die Atmosphäre da stärker wirkt. Jedenfalls, wenn man diese Solarzellen vor sich hat auf der Erde und die in Ruhe angucken kann, mit dem Elektronenmikroskop, Zelle für Zelle durchleuchtet, dann kann man da Tausende von Grad an zählen. Und das ist natürlich eine fantastische Datenbasis für uns. Und das fließt auch in unsere Modelle mit ein.
Das heißt, was gemacht wird, ist sozusagen einerseits durch Simulation, andererseits auch durch Anpassung der Datenbasis aufgrund realer Messung. Plus der tatsächlichen Beobachtung von dem, was ich so beobachte, das ist quasi so eine Kartographie des Schrottes.
Ja, also ich könnte es nicht besser zusammenfassen. Also das ist das, was wir machen. Wir benutzen alle zur Verfügung stehenden Quellen, eigene Messungen, Impact-Daten aus dem All selber, den amerikanischen Katalog nicht zuletzt, um uns da mit unser eigenes Bild von der Umgebung im Weltraum zu bauen.
Macht man manchmal so ein eigenes Bild, oder steht dieser Katalog dann auch allen anderen Wissenschaftlern zur Verfügung?
Ja, da wollte ich auch gerade drauf kommen, denn wir machen das nicht nur für uns, sondern dieses Modell hat einen Nutzen. Und zwar stellen wir das zur Verfügung in Form einer Software, die nennt sich Master, Meteorite and Space-Tubular Terrestrial Environment Reference. Und dort kann jeder Satellitenbetreiber seine Mission quasi virtuell durch die Weltraumschrottumgebung fliegen lassen, also durch unser Modell fliegen lassen. Und das Modell liefert dann eine Vorhersage über die Zahl der Einschläge in Abhängigkeit von der Größe und die Richtung, aus der sie kommen. Und auch mit der Geschwindigkeit, die da zu erwarten ist. Und dann kann er entscheiden, welche Maßnahmen oder ob Maßnahmen erforderlich sind, die die Mission sicherer machen. Ob man vielleicht eine andere Höhe wählt. Ob man vielleicht kritische Komponenten im Satelliten so positioniert, dass sie nicht gerade in Richtung des Hauptflusses von Objekten zeigen. Dass man die also quasi so ein bisschen abschirmt durch weniger kritische Komponenten. Man hat so ein paar limitierte Designmaßnahmen, die man zur Verfügung hat, um das Risiko da zu minimieren. Und das Modell liefert genau diese Informationen.
Aber es ist schon so ein bisschen hilflos, ne?
Ja, es klingt so nach, wir retten was zu retten.
Das klingt so nach Tin-Fall-Head, wenn man sich so eine Aluminiumfolie über den Kopf zieht und sagt, der große Stein wird nicht auf mich fallen können.
Ja, abhauen ist keine Lösung für manche. Das heißt, bestimmte Orbitregionen zu vermeiden, geht nicht unbedingt, weil sich bestimmte Missionen nur an bestimmten Regionen erfüllen lassen. Es kann sein, Satelliten natürlich bis zum Geht nicht mehr panzern, aber das kostet natürlich Geld. Masse im Weltall kostet Geld. Es gibt clevere Konzepte für Schilde, die vermeiden, dass man da dicke Aluminiumblöcke an den Satelliten schrauben muss. Es gibt also auch leicht gewichtigere Lösungen, aber es nimmt Raum und Masse ein und macht die Raumfahrt teuer. Das heißt, es wäre besser, wenn man das Geld in die Vermeidung von Weltraumschrott stecken würde. Das ist auch ein wichtiges Feld, an dem wir arbeiten. Meine Kollegen und ich beschäftigen uns damit, wie effektiv es ist, die und diejenigen Maßnahmen durchzuführen, im Hinblick auf das Anwachsen der Population.
Aber bleiben wir vielleicht noch mal kurz, was man jetzt dagegen tun kann. Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, man hat diese Datenbank, wo man jetzt eine Mission plant, und sich dann auch eine entsprechende Höhe ausdenkt und dann das Gegencheckt mit dem, was man sozusagen so weiß oder glaubt zu wissen, was man sich so herbeisimuliert hat, wie das da so aussieht, dann ergibt das ja sozusagen so eine gewisse Schadenswahrscheinlichkeit. Und wie kann man da, also, ich meine, gibt es überhaupt eine Möglichkeit da, also gut, die Wahrscheinlichkeit würde wahrscheinlich eher in so eine passive Maßnahme wie Schilde fließen. Andere Sache ist ja, wenn man jetzt konkret treckt, also ich meine, wenn man jetzt sozusagen die Fußbälle, die da langfliegen, wenn man die halt auch wirklich genau weiß, wo die sind, und wenn die jetzt in irgendeiner Form in die Nähe geraten von etwas, was fliegt, was für Chancen wird dann ausgewichen, wird dann eine Rakete gestartet und dann geht man erstmal einen halben Stockwerk höher. Wie genau kann man die trecken?
Ja, also da sprichst du eigentlich unser Alltagsgeschäft an, Kollisionsvermeidung. Und zwar diese 16.000 Objekte, die wir kennen, den kann man auch ausweichen. Wenn ich genau weiß, wo ein Objekt ist, und die Amerikaner wissen das mit einer Genauigkeit von mehreren, also um die 10 Meter bis 20 Meter, je nachdem in welche Richtung, in welcher Bahnhöhe. Also äußerst genau. Das ist ungefähr die Genauigkeit, mit der wir selber unsere eigenen Satelliten trecken. Aber die tun das mit passiven, toten Objekten. Das heißt, es zeigt, dass da ein gewaltiges Überwachungsnetzwerk dahinter steckt. Die Daten, die die Amerikaner haben, sind genau. Ausreichend, um zuverlässig Ausweichmanöver planen zu können. Und auch die, wir nennen das Conjunction-Ereignisse, sicher vorherzusagen, für jedes Ereignis eine Kollisionswahrscheinlichkeit zu berechnen und einen ordnungsgemäßen Ausreichmanöver zu planen. Das passiert, das ist heute Alltag. Besonders wenn man in 800 Kilometer Höhe unterwegs ist, kommt man eigentlich um eine wöchentliche Warnung heute nicht mehr drumrum.
Wie früh lässt sich so eine Vorhersage machen?
Man kann beliebig früh anfangen, aber sie wird immer zuverlässiger, je dichter man an den Event-Zeitpunkt herankommt.
Also wann ist es so genau, dass man auch konkret darauf eine Maßnahme stützen könnte?
Ungefähr drei Tage vorher hat man die beiden Objekte so genau, dass man sagen kann, das ist die Geometrie, mit der es zu dieser Konjunktion, also zu dem Begegnungsereignis kommt. Und dann muss man entscheiden, wie man diese Geometrie verändert durch ein Manöver, mit dem sich alle Beteiligten sicher fühlen.
Das heißt, wenn man dieses 800-km-Beispiel mit Iridium aufgreift, das haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt. Iridium ist ja dieses Satelliten-Telefonnetz, mit den, ich glaube, wie viele waren es? 66 Satelliten, die so herumfliegen. Das heißt, die checken regelmäßig auf Basis eurer Datenbank, was so abgeht, und wenn irgendwas zu nahe rankommt, dann wird da in der Missionsplanung das eingearbeitet und sagen, okay, den bremsen wir mal ab oder den fliegen wir mal kurz ein bisschen höher, damit er das dann sozusagen umgeht. Wie weit muss man dann weg, um sicher zu sein, dass man nicht doch noch erwischt wird? Da ist ja auch Ungenauigkeit drin.
Ich freue mich erst mal, dass du der ESA zutraust, so eine genaue Datenbank zu haben. Ich muss richtigerweise dazu fügen, dass die Daten, die für die Kollisionsvermeidung tauglich sind, die kommen ausschließlich aus den USA. Nur jemand, der so ein Überwachungsnetzwerk hat für die Amerikaner, kann genaue Daten liefern. Unser Modell, was bis 1 mm und so weiter hinuntergeht, das ist ein statistisches Modell. Das heißt, es liefert Wahrscheinlichkeiten für einen Orbit. Wir benutzen auch die Daten der Amerikaner. So tut das auch iridium. Und wenn ein Manöver notwendig wird, je genauer die Daten sind, umso kleiner ist auch das Manöver. Wenn man große Unsicherheiten in der Orbitinformation hat und man möchte kein Risiko haben, dann muss man ein gewaltig großes Manöver fliegen, um sozusagen aus dem gesamten Unsicherheitsbereich zu umfliegen. Je genauer diese Weltraumüberwachungsdaten sind, umso kleiner die Manöver, umso spritzspannender und umso kürzer ist auch die Mission betroffen und beeinträchtigt. Das sind alles wichtige Aspekte, denn jedes Manöver kostet Geld und Zeit. Iridium muss das für 66 Satelliten machen. Und nachdem sie einmal getroffen worden sind, machen sie das auch, hoffe ich, gut genug. Wir machen das auch. Und wir hatten dieses Jahr bereits 7 Ausweichmanöver bei 3 Satelliten, alle in der Bahnhöhe von 800 km.
Und weiß man auch, was da sozusagen gerade die Bedrohung war? Ist das konkret diese Kollision gewesen?
Also wir wissen natürlich in dem Fall von iridium, was da eingeschlagen ist. Und auch, wenn wir eine Warnung bekommen aus den USA oder mit den Daten der Amerikaner, weil sie ja aus dem Überwachungsnetzwerk kommt, wissen wir natürlich auch, welches Objekt dahinter steckt. Wenn es zum Beispiel ein Trümmerstück ist, wissen wir in der Regel auch, aus welchem Mutterobjekt das entstammt. Wenn es ein intakter Satellit ist, dann wissen wir auch den Namen und wem es gehört. Die Information liefert ein gutes Überwachungsnetzwerk, wie es die Amerikaner haben und wie es die Europäer bauen wollen. Nicht zuletzt diese Problematik, und das muss ich an der Stelle einwerfen, hat in Europa dazu geführt, dass man sich entschlossen hat, ein eigenes Überwachungsnetzwerk auf die Beine zu stellen.
Da gibt es doch bestimmte schicke Namen dazu, oder?
Ja, es nennt sich SSA, Space Situational Awareness System. Beinhaltet die Weltraumüberwachung, beinhaltet aber auch das Weltraumwetter. Das Weltraumwetter ist letztendlich alle Effekte, die sich im Zusammenspiel vom Sonnenwind, also von der Partikelstrahlung der Sonne und dem Erdmagnetfeld ergeben. Das hat Konsequenzen auf elektrische Bauteile im All, aber auch auf der Erde. Und nicht zum Schluss auch Asteroiden. Nicht alle Asteroiden, aber die Asteroiden, die der Erde irgendwann mal gefährlich nahe kommen könnten. Und zu so einem globalen Einschlagsereignis führen könnten. In nahe und ferner Zukunft.
Das heißt, das SSA geht in seiner Planung noch sehr viel weiter als das Überwachungsnetzwerk der Amerikaner.
Genau.
Übernimmt aber im Prinzip auch diese Funktionalität zusätzlich.
Übernimmt, beinhaltet diese Funktionalität. Versucht, genau zu sein, versucht zuverlässig zu sein. Es ist letztendlich designt. Es ist von unseren Mitgliedstaaten gefordert, dass dieses System eine hohe Zuverlässigkeit liefert im puncto Kollisionsvermeidung. Das heißt, es ist also eins der Auslegungskriterien für dieses Netzwerk, dass man damit zuverlässig Kollisionsvermeidung betreiben kann.
Was muss man denn da am Boden alles in Stellung bringen, damit man so ein Netzwerk überhaupt aufbauen kann?
Ah ja, da muss man einiges bewegen. Man braucht zunächst mal einen Überwachungsradar. Das heißt, nicht nur ein Radar, kein Radar mit einer Schüssel, was ein bekanntes Objekt nachverfolgen kann, wie wir es heute in Europa schon haben, sondern ein Radar, das ohne irgendeine Information über die Objekte im All quasi von null auf anfangen kann, ein Objekt zu entdecken. Das heißt, es muss letztendlich regelmäßig einen bestimmten Bereich im Weltraum abscannen, sozusagen, um ohne a priori Information neue Objekte zu erfassen und dann gültig nachverfolgen zu können.
So ein Radar-Suchscheinwerfer, der die gleichen Bereiche abtastet und dann den Vergleich zieht, wie es vorher, wie es nachher.
Ja, das heißt, man muss viel Energie darauf verwenden, auch in Bereiche zu gucken, wo man letztendlich nichts gefunden hat. Man muss letztendlich wie ein Suchscheinwerfer viele Sachen ableuchten, das kostet viel Energie. Das ist auch ein gewaltiges Thema. Aber wenn man das hat, dann ist man völlig autark in der Lage, einen Objektkatalog aufzubauen. Da reicht ja auch nicht eine Station.
Da muss man ja rund um die Erde.
Wenn man es clever macht, kommt man vielleicht sogar mit einer Station zurecht. Wenn man die geografische Breite gut genug wählt und auch den Suchbereich gut ausgelegt, dann kann man mit einem System schon eine Menge machen.
Ist nicht egal.
Equator hat den Vorteil, dass wirklich jedes Objekt irgendwann mal vorbeikommt. Denn jedes Objekt muss mal durch die Equator-Ebene tauchen bei jedem Umlauf. Allerdings kommen die Objekte dann selten vorbei. Wenn man weiter nach oben geht, dann verliert man zwar die Objekte mit kleiner Bahnneigung, weil die nicht an größeren geografischen Breiten vorbeikommen. Wenn man es oben bei höheren geografischen Breiten, Deutschland, Skandinavien, noch höher aufstellt, verpasst man diese niedrig inklinierten Objekte. Aber dafür bekommt man ganz, ganz viele Überflüge. Man kann also viele Möglichkeiten vermessen, diejenigen Objekte, die so weit nach oben kommen.
Was heißt, man kriegt viele Überflüge?
Das heißt, ein Objekt, was letztendlich über die Pole fliegt, macht das ungefähr 16 Mal pro Tag in den Bahnhöfen, über die wir hier sprechen. Das heißt, wenn man das Radar besonders weit nördlich oder südlich positioniert, kann man das 16 Mal pro Tag vermessen. Und das führt dazu, dass man eine besonders gute Genauigkeit erreicht. Wenn man es am Äquator positioniert, dann ermischt man das vielleicht nur einmal pro Tag. Und das führt dazu, dass die Genauigkeit nicht sonderlich hoch sein wird am Ende.
Aber ich meine, die können auch im Prinzip in jede beliebige Richtung fliegen. Die müssen auch gar nicht über die Pole fliegen.
Also fast 80% der Objekte, die wir erkennen, haben Bahnneigung, die dazu führen, dass sie oberhalb von 50, 60 Grad geografischer Weite vorbeifliegen. Das hängt viel mit den Startplätzen und der Mission zusammen. Der erdnahe Bereich besteht insbesondere auch von Objekten, die für Erdbeobachtung gemacht sind. Und Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten möchten möglichst die ganze Erde sehen. Und das erreicht man am besten, indem man die Satelliten über die Pole fliegen lässt und sich die Erde quasi unter der Bahn hindurchdrehen lässt, sodass man quasi jedes Mal jeden Ort der Erde einmal überfliegt. Und sich quasi die Erddrehung dabei zu Nutze macht. Dieser Effekt funktioniert natürlich nur bei hoch geneigten Bahnen. Und das ist also die primäre Anwendung in dem Bereich.
Okay, also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, die Tatsache, dass da sozusagen mehr zu holen wäre, resultiert nur daraus, dass in diesen Bahnen mehr Projekte gestartet werden. Und man davon ausgehen kann, dass da mehr Weltraum schreut. Es gibt jetzt keine physikalischen Bedingungen, die grundsätzlich in diese Bahnen zwingen würden. Die könnten auch genauso in jeder beliebigen Diagonale um die Erde herumfliegen. Aber von daher würde es quasi sinnvoll sein. Das ist aber noch nicht entschieden.
Das ist noch nicht entschieden.
Aber es ist durchaus genauso vorstellbar, dass man jetzt sagt, wir gehen jetzt an die Pole. Weil da sehen wir alles, was da sozusagen in diesen typischen Erdbeobachtungsbahnen kreist, sehr häufig und nicht an den Äquator.
Ja genau. Also das System muss halt der Verteilung der Objekte folgen, wie wir sie vorliegen haben.
Das heißt, dieses SSA befindet sich im Wesentlichen erstmal noch in der Planung, aber man weiß, dass man es haben will.
Wir wissen, dass wir es haben wollen. Wir arbeiten jetzt erst seit drei Jahren daran, an so einer Art Vorläuferprogramm. In zwei Jahren werden wir einen großen Entscheidungspunkt haben, wo die ESA-Ministerratskonferenz über die Weiterführung und letztendliche Umsetzung des Programms entscheidet. In dieser jetzigen vorbereitenden Phase arbeiten wir an genau den Aspekten, wie du gerade angesprochen hast. Wo müsste so ein Radar stehen?
Aber die Tatsache, dass das alles so bedrohlich ist und dass es vor allem die Missionen potenziell sehr teuer macht, dürfte ja auch für ein gesteigertes Interesse dieses Themas schon bereits gesorgt haben, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, wir wären nicht so weit gekommen mit unserer vorläufigen Entwicklungsphase, wie wir sie jetzt haben, wenn nicht offensichtlich geworden wäre, wie zum Beispiel im Januar 2009 als Iridium mit dem Kosmos-Satellin kollidiert ist, wie die Situation wirklich bestellt ist im Weltall. Also ganz richtig, wenn wir...
Kam das überraschend für die Gemeinde?
Also für uns nicht. Es musste irgendwann kommen.
Aber wie konnte das denn überhaupt passieren? Ich meine, das ist ja ein Riesenobjekt, dieser Cosmos, der müsste doch eigentlich in dieser Tracking-Database auch drin gewesen sein.
Ja, ist drin gewesen, ja.
Aber?
Sind zu der Zeitpunkt noch keine regelmäßigen Warnungen von dem US-Überwachungsnetzwerk an die Satellitenbetreiber gegangen, sondern nur an Nutzlasten, die unter amerikanischer Regierungskontrolle standen. Zudem, man kann natürlich, ist es der Stand, jedoch andere Daten zur Verfügung, mit denen man auch in gewissem Maße Kollisionsvermeidung betreiben kann. Aber als Satellitenbetreiber von 66 Satelliten hat man täglich mehrere Warnungen. Und auf dieser Grundlage lässt sich das nicht effektiv machen. Nach diesem Ereignis sind die Amerikaner dazu übergegangen, von sich aus automatisch jeden Satellitenbetreiber, den sie kennen, den sie in ihrer Datenbank haben, von dem sie Kontaktdaten haben, zu warnen. Auf Basis ihrer hochpräzisen Daten, die bis dato auch nicht veröffentlicht worden sind.
Was ja auch in ihrem eigenen Interesse ist.
Letztendlich aus ihrem eigenen Interesse haben sie sich die Verantwortung selbst aufgeladen, ihre Daten dazu zu verwenden, rechtzeitig die Satellitenbetreiber zu warnen. Die Entscheidung etwas zu machen, liegt immer noch beim Betreiber. Das heißt, natürlich kann die US-Luftwaffe, die man vorschreiben, zu manövrieren, wenn ihnen der Satellit nicht gehört. Aber allein die Tatsache, dass wir jetzt Zugang zu hochpräzisen Daten bekommen, die vorher verwert waren und für die letztendlich der amerikanische Steuerzahler aufkommt und die Kosten, die damit verbunden sind, sind hoch, zeigt schon, dass sich einiges bewegt hat. Auslöser war diese Kollision zwischen Iridium und Kosmos.
Gibt es denn überhaupt schon so eine Art internationales Weltraumrecht, wie man sich auf den hohen Meeren irgendwann mal einigen muss?
Ja, also...
Das würde man ja jetzt erwarten. Ich meine, das würde jetzt ein Betreiber nicht reagieren auf so eine Warnung und keine Maßnahme ergreifen. Abgesehen davon, dass es jetzt zu seinem eigenen Schaden ist, ist es ja auch automatisch der Schaden für alle.
Richtig, ja. Also es ist ein internationaler Raum. Jeder ist durch solche Ereignisse gleichermaßen betroffen. Man sollte eigentlich erwarten, dass es ein Weltraumrecht gibt, was darauf vorbereitet ist. Aber das Weltraumrecht, was heute vorliegt, ist größtenteils aus den 60er-Jahren. Als Raumfahrt eine Sache von Nationen war. Also eine Staatsangelegenheit war. Und wesentlich vor den entscheidenden Entdeckungen aus der Weltraumschrott-Gemeinde stammt. Und somit keine verbindenden Maßnahmen enthält, die in irgendeiner Form vorschreiben, zum Beispiel Kollision zu vermeiden, ein Objekt aus einem besonders belasteten Orbit wieder zu entfernen und so weiter.
Das heißt, das Thema kann man also wirklich als angekommen ansehen. Also es gibt zu sagen, es steht im Mittelpunkt. Alle wollen was daran machen oder wird irgendwo noch gebremst? Oder sind schon alle irgendwie ganz verrückt?
Also gebremst wird, das Thema steht auf der Tagesordnung, aber unter Technikern besteht auch der Konsens darüber, was gemacht werden muss, um den Anstieg der Weltraumschrottpopulation zu vermindern. Da besteht schon seit 2002 ein Maßnahmenkatalog. Alles technische Maßnahmen, die konsequent durchgeführt werden müssen. Und dann können wir auch genau woher sagen, wie sich das Environment damit verhält. Es hapert an der Umsetzung in verbindliches Recht. Die gibt es heute nicht. Und mein Eindruck ist, dass es auch auf lange Sicht nicht geben wird.
Also wenn sich die Techniker so einig sind, was man denn jetzt tun kann. Im Prinzip ist es ja wie bei richtigen Müll auch. Das eine ist, wie wird man ihn los. Und das andere ist, wie vermeidet man sozusagen, dass überhaupt welcher entsteht. Inwiefern ist denn jetzt diese Müllvermeidung schon Teil der Programme?
Im Fall der ESA haben wir uns seit 2008 selbst verpflichtet, folgende Maßnahmen zu machen. Kollisionsvermeidung, das Einhalten von einer Lebensdauerbeschränkung.
Was heißt Kollisionsvermeidung? Wollt ihr das nicht alle vermeiden?
Wir können natürlich nur die Kollisionen vermeiden, die mit unserem Satelliten zusammenhängen. Wir sehen zu, dass unser Satellit Ausweichmanöver fliegt.
Das dürfte ja bei den anderen auch so sein, oder? Ist das nicht Standard?
Das ist nicht bei allen in ihrem Programm verbindlich vorgeschrieben. Es gibt Agenturen und wir können natürlich auch nur aus ESA-Sicht den ESA, von der ESA entwickelten und betriebenen Satelliten, solche Vorschreibungen machen. Wann immer jemand einen kommerziellen Satellit entwickelt und startet, haben wir denen nichts zu sagen, außer ihm Empfehlungen an die Hand zu geben. Und auch Software, mit denen man das Problem lösen kann oder unseren eigenen Kollisionsvermeidungsservice anzubieten. Wichtig ist, dass wir als Vorbild agieren. Und das tun wir, das tun aber auch die anderen nationalen Raumfahrtagenturen, wie die französische, die deutsche, die italienische, und die englische, und die amerikanische und russische. Und zwischen auch Chinesen und Inder. Die Umsetzung ist noch unterschiedlich effizient in den einzelnen Agenturen, um das mal vorsichtig auszudrücken. Aber Kollisionsvermeidung, sagen wir mal, macht man nicht nur zum Schutze des Weltraums, man macht das natürlich auch zum Schutz von seinen eigenen Satelliten. Das ist das, wo jeder natürliches Interesse dran hat. Es gibt aber Maßnahmen, die kosten Geld und die bringen der Mission erst mal nichts. Und dazu gehört zum Beispiel, dass man seine Nutzlast und auch die Raketenoberstufe aus dem Orbit entfernt, wenn der Orbit unterhalb von 2000 Kilometern liegt, also da, wo besonders viel los ist. Und das nach 25 Jahren, spätestens nach Ablauf von 25 Jahren nach Ende der Mission. Das heißt, wir müssen sozusagen die Zielscheibe für zukünftige Kollision, unser Objekt, unsere große Masse, unsere große Fläche im All zurück zur Erde bringen, um sicherzustellen, dass wir auf die Art und Weise zukünftige Kollision vermeiden.
25 Jahre, das klingt ja jetzt erst mal nach einer ganzen Menge.
Klingt nach einer ganzen Menge, aber man musste bedenken, wenn man nichts machen würde, würde das Objekt 200 Jahre da oben bleiben und der Unterschied zwischen 25 und 200 Jahren ist groß. Das heißt, der Unterschied zwischen diesen beiden Zahlen muss als Energie investiert werden, um das Raumfahrzeug abzubremsen und zum Wiedereintritt zu bringen.
Also konkret redet man jetzt hier vor allem von der Raketenoberstufe, also das, was letzten Endes die Nutzlast in den Orbit bringt und nachdem sie das dann getan hat, dass man eben dann noch mal zündet und die Oberstufe wiederum nach unten befördert.
Ja, die Raketenoberstufe, genau wie du gesagt hast, aber auch die Nutzlast selber, der Satellit. Der Satellit, auch der ist manövrierfähig, wenn er eine gewisse Größe hat normalerweise. Und die Treibstoffvorräte, die der Satellit an Bord hat, die müssen dazu reichen, den nach Ende der Mission auf eine Bahn zu bringen, die tief genug ist, dass die atmosphärische Restwirkung den letztendlich innerhalb von 25 Jahren zum Absturz bringt.
Wenn man jetzt von dieser 800 km Höhe ausgeht, wie tief müsste man sinken?
Man müsste noch so auf 550 km runtergehen. Ab da verschwinden normale Objekte von der Höhe aus, normalerweise innerhalb von 25 Jahren.
Ah, okay, 550. Und ist das so viel Energie, diese 300 km?
Es ist viel, ja.
Wenn man den Treibstoff, den man dafür verwendet, in die Mission stecken könnte, also sozusagen in die Pflege des Orbits und in die Lage, dann könnte man die Mission noch einige Jahre weiter betreiben. Ah, verstehe. Und man muss es quasi umrechnen in äquivalente Missionslebensdauer, die man damit aufgibt und damit auch den Umsatz, den man macht, aufgibt.
Da zeigt sich dann sozusagen die Problematik, das durchzusetzen und vielleicht auch rechtlich verbindlich zu machen.
Ja, ich meine, ganz genau. Denn insbesondere nach endender Mission, wenn das Lied schon abgeschrieben ist, ist quasi der volle Umsatz identisch mit dem Gewinn. Und auf den muss man dann verzichten, indem man den restlichen Treibstoff in Entfernungsmaßnahmen investiert. Wir sind in dem erdnahen Weltraum nicht so viele Missionen kommerziell. Aber in der geestationären Bahn ist es der Fall. In der geestationären Bahn wird viel Geld mit Kommunikations-Dienstleistungen gemacht. Und da haben wir auch das Problem. Da fordern auch die Techniker, dass man nach dem Betrieb den Satelliten entfernt. Jetzt kann man von 36.000 km unmöglich erwarten, dass der Satellit zurück zur Erde kommt. Aber man kann als Kompromiss erwarten, dass der Satellit auf eine, wir nennen es Friedhofsbahn, geschickt wird. Die liegt ungefähr 300 km und weiter darüber. Wenn man da den Satelliten am Ende kreisförmig einschießt, da gehen wieder die Treibstoffvorräte, die ungefähr einem Monat Betriebsdauer entsprechen, bald rauf. Bei so mittelgroßen Kommunikationssatelliten bedeutet das ungefähr eine Million Umsatz, auf die da verzichtet wird. Hier ist die große Überraschung, wenn man sich die Vergangenheit anguckt, dass gerade kommerzielle Satellitenbetreiber das eigentlich ganz gut machen. Obwohl es keine verbindliche gesetzliche Vorschreibung dafür gibt, machen die das auf freiwilliger Basis. Hilfreich ist dabei, dass sie gerne die Stelle, an der sie ihren Satelliten geparkt haben, auf diesem Ring, für den Nachfolgesatelliten wieder nutzen wollen. Und sie dafür eine Freigabe brauchen, von der ITU, International Telecommunication Union. Das heißt, jeder Parkplatz ist sozusagen, dass er wird. In diesem Orbit-Bereich haben wir quasi einen Druckmechanismus, das ist die ITU. Aber auch da hat sich besonders bei den kommerziellen Betreibern bereits die Erkenntnis durchgesetzt, nicht nur wegen der ITU, sondern dass auch allein geografisch der Platz da sein muss. Denn sie merken auch, dass wenn von rechts und links ein Satellit in ihre Kontrollbox driftet und wieder heraus, dass das den Betrieb stört, dass da ja einer drauf gucken muss, dass man eventuell ein Ausweichmanöver macht. Während des Manövers ist der Satellit vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig brauchbar, geht wieder Zeit verloren und Geld verloren. Das heißt, hier offenbart sich ein bisschen direkter diese ganzen Konsequenzen des Problems. Insofern sehen wir bei den kommerziellen Betreibern eine viel bessere Erfolgsquote, was das Entfernen von Objekten nach dem Betrieb angeht, als bei staatlichen. Und zwischen den einzelnen Nationen sieht man noch mal große Unterschiede. Ein Kollege von mir, der führt da schon seit einer Zeit leidenschaftliche Statistiken. Da zeigt sich genau dieser Effekt.
Und diese 300 Kilometer Friedhofsbahn, ist das sicher genug? Da hauen die sich ja dann auch irgendwann alle kaputt.
Ja, also es schützt nicht vor Fragmentationen auf diesem Orbit. Wenn dort etwas explodiert, dann erreichen die Trümmer allein dadurch, dass sie einen Schubs kriegen durch die Explosionen. Wir nennen das Delta-Velocity. Da erreichen die locker stationäre Bahn. Und führen dazu Unheil.
Ist es sozusagen angeraten, dass sie dann auch ihren Treibstoff vollständig verbrennen bei dieser Aktion?
Richtig. Ein weiterer Punkt aus dem Maßnahmenkatalog ist, dass man das Objekt passiviert. Wir nennen das Passivieren. Das heißt, Entfernen des restlichen Brennstoffs. Entweder durch ein komplettes Ausbrennen oder am besten durch ein Ventil, in dem man sicherstellt, dass die Tanks komplett geleert werden. Neben dem Treibstofftank ist auch noch mal ein Drucktank, in dem Gas gehalten wird, der den Treibstoff unter Druck setzt, damit der quasi auch das letzte Tropfen rausgequetscht wird aus der Düse. Auch dieser Drucktank muss dann quasi entlüftet werden. Auch alle anderen Energieträger an Bord, die Batterie, die überladen werden kann, auch mechanische Drehungen, wie sie z.B. in den Kreiseln und Dreirädern sind, sollte man idealerweise abbremsen. Dass quasi sämtliche kinetische, chemische, elektrische Energie aus dem Satelliten verschwindet.
Und es dann einfach nur so ein bisschen Restmüll ist, den man dann leider auf der Erde verloren hat sozusagen.
Ein völlig totes Objekt ist.
Das ist dann auch wirklich der finale Rohstoff-Export. Irgendwann liegen sozusagen die ganzen Rohstoffe da oben. Ja, die Goldbahn.
Ja, ich meine, es ist tatsächlich viel Gold an Bord. Häufig sehen die Satelliten goldig aus von außen. Das ist die Isolationsfolie, die da draußen dran hängt. Die auch Ärger macht, denn wir haben den Eindruck, dass nach einigen Jahren im Weltraum sich diese Folien ablösen. Und dann als einzelne Folienstückchen durch die Gegend wabern. Man kann das von der Erde aus mit Teleskopen ganz gut beobachten.
Und das ist auch Gold oder sieht das mit Gold aus?
Gold beschichtet.
Ja, es bringt nicht viel. Der Anteil an den Gesamtkosten des Satelliten ist klein.
Aber wenn da irgendwann so viel rumfliegt da oben, dass man da nur noch die Hand aufhalten muss und das ganze Gold, das ist ja sozusagen das neue Klondike.
Ja, vielleicht Rio's von elektronischen Bauteilen, Aluminium, wenn das mal auf der Erde knapp wird im Weltraum. Mehr als 80 Prozent des Materials ist Aluminium. Und das fliegt darum. Ich meine, diese geerstationäre Friedhofsbahn, das klingt erstmal ganz nett, aber es kann nur ein Kompromiss sein. Denn wer weiß, ob genau diese Bahn nicht vielleicht irgendwann mal interessant wird für eine Anwendung. Wenn wir da unser Aluminium-Material-Lager einrichten, dann ist das vielleicht auch nicht sonderlich ratsam. Aber sagen wir mal so, wir sind froh über diesen Kompromiss. Mit einer durchschnittlichen Erfolgsrate von 50 Prozent. Das könnte besser sein. Aber immerhin.
Was heißt das, wenn es nicht klappt, bleibt der trotzdem?
Meistens klappt es nur so ein bisschen. Das heißt, dass der Treibstoff dann doch nicht ausgereicht hat, um das Manöver zu Ende durchzuführen. Oder dass man einfach den Resttreibstoff nicht ordentlich schätzen konnte. Das ist übrigens eine gewaltige technische Herausforderung. Restlichen Treibstoff zu schätzen, das klingt einfach. Man guckt einfach auf die Tanknadel im Auto. Aber beim Satelliten in 36.000 Kilometer Entfernung ist das nicht so einfach. Man hat heute noch keine richtig zuverlässige Methode dafür.
Das heißt, es kann auch einfach sein, dass gar kein Sprit mehr da ist?
Gar kein Sprit mehr da ist und ein Betreiber, der entscheidet natürlich zugunsten des Betriebs im Fall eines Zweifels.
Wir waren ja bei den Vermeidungsstrategien und im Prinzip haben wir jetzt zwei Sachen besprochen. Auf der einen Seite ist, wenn was kommt, ausweichen. Das klingt irgendwie logisch. Das andere ist, wenn nicht mehr im Betrieb, dann bitte schön wegschieben. Im Falle beim Geostationären nach außen parken, weil die Energie, um zurückzuführen, unhindrig da wäre. Beziehungsweise würde man die mitnehmen, dann wär es wahrscheinlich alles überhaupt nicht mehr zu bezahlen. Auf der anderen Seite, das Absenken, das klingt ja irgendwie auch ganz logisch. Allerdings dieser Gedanke, dass man dann immer wieder alles auf die Erde plumpsen lässt, ist ja auch so ein bisschen merkwürdig. Also was, man kennt dieses Konzept des Verglühens, was verglüht überhaupt unter welchen Bedingungen und was passiert dabei? Ist das Verglühen dann nicht auch noch ein Problem für sich?
Ja, das ist auch ein Problem. Man muss allerdings sagen, je eher die Sachen herunterkommen, umso besser. Ein Objekt, das unkontrolliert abstürzt, kann im Prinzip überall herunterkommen auf der Erde. Der einzige sozusagen Randbedingung ist die Bahnneigung. Es kann nur da runterkommen, wo die Gebiete über die Bahn führt. Da aber alle Objekte letztendlich mehr oder weniger polar sind, also über beide Pole fliegen, ist jeder Punkt auf der Erde ein Kandidat für jeder Ort erreichbar. Sodass man, das ist eigentlich nur eine Frage der Bevölkerungsdichte, wie groß die Gefahr ist. Und wenn man die Objekte jetzt herunterholt, und wir wissen, dass in 200 Jahren die Bevölkerung sicherlich größer ist als heute, es macht natürlich Sinn, das möglichst früh zu machen. Trotzdem überlassen wir das in der Regel nicht den Zufall. Das heißt, wenn wir bei der ESA sagen, sobald sich herausstellt durch Analyse, dass ein Objekt beim Wiedereintritt, sagen wir mal, wir nennen das Casualty Risk, also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass einer oder mehr zu Schaden kommen durch Verletzungen, größer ist als 10 auf minus 4, also 1 zu 10.000, erlauben wir nicht einen Zufallswiedereintritt. Also ein Wiedereintritt allein durch die Kräfte der Atmosphäre irgendwann nach 25 oder mehr Jahren. Sondern dann müssen wir einen gezielten Absturz machen. Dann müssen wir gezielt einen Punkt auf der Erde anpeilen. Und das ist in der Regel der südpazifische Ozean. Das ist so die am wenigsten besiedelte Landfläche. Den peilen wir an. Das kostet natürlich noch mehr Energie. Denn dann reicht es nicht, die Bahn auf 550 km abzusenken. Sondern dann muss man sie auf 0 absenken.
Also bis zum Schluss muss gefeuert werden?
Ja, es muss der eine Punkt der Bahn, die Bahn kann ellipsenförmig sein, aber der erdniedrigste Punkt muss auf der Erdoberfläche liegen. Nur dann ist sichergestellt, dass man genau den Zielpunkt auf der Erde erreicht, der außerhalb von den Landmassen liegt. Das haben wir zum ersten Mal gemacht mit dem europäischen Transportraumschiff ATV. Und es gibt ganz spektakuläre Bilder von dem Wiedereintritt. Das ist auch beobachtet worden. Wenn man weiß, wo er stattfindet, dann kann man auch Flugzeuge dahinschicken, die das mit optischen Sensoren beobachten. Und wir haben beobachtet, wie gut wir die Zielfläche getroffen haben. Weil das das erste Mal ist, dass wir so ein Ereignis hatten und geplant haben. Und es hat sich herausgestellt, dass die Vorhersagen ganz gut eingehalten worden sind.
Also das ATV, das versorgt die ISS, die International Space Station. Aber wird sozusagen nicht wiederverwendet.
Wird nicht wiederverwendet. Hat 20 Tonnen, ist also eine gewaltige Masse. Normaler Satellit hat so ein bis zwei Tonnen. 20 Tonnen. Und ja, man kann so sagen, dass bei größeren Objekten 30 Prozent der Masse den Erdboden erreichen. Man hat immer wieder Materialien an Bord, wie rostfreier Stahl, Titan, Materialien, die viel Druck aushalten müssen. Die Drucktanks sind daraus gebaut. Auch Kohlenfaser verstärkter Kunststoff ist etwas, was wieder eintritt, in der Regel überlebt.
Was überlebt denn auf keinen Fall?
Also Aluminium überlebt den Wiedereintritt normalerweise nicht. Plastik, Kupfer, Selten. Glas überlebt den Glas. Wenn immer Glas zum Beispiel als Spiegel, Weltraumteleskopen zum Einsatz kommt, ist das eine kritische Sache. Also Glas in großen Blöcken ist ein Problem.
Was passiert denn mit dem Aluminium, wenn es auf die Atmosphäre trifft?
Also wenn wir beim Wiedereintritt haben, haben wir große aerodynamische Kräfte, aber auch aerothermische Effekte. Das heißt, die Zusammenwirkung von der hohen Geschwindigkeit, mit der wir auf die Erdatmosphäre treffen, führt zu einer Aufheizung der Materialien. Das Material schmilzt dann regelrecht auf. Und das in der Regel, wenn die Wände dünn genug sind, sogar komplett. Das heißt, es schmilzt komplett auf und verdampft und verschwindet komplett.
Was heißt das verschwinden? Ich meine, es verschwindet ja nicht.
Also es wird gasförmig und konsolidiert, sich nicht wieder zu klumpen, sondern verteilt sich in der Atmosphäre.
Aluminiumdampf.
Aluminiumdampf, ja genau.
Muss man sich darüber irgendwelche Gedanken machen?
Nein.
Nein, wir können froh sein, dass es verschwindet. Denn wenn es nicht verschwindet, dann müssen wir uns Gedanken machen.
Das heißt, es geht dann sozusagen, die Atmosphäre überregnet sich irgendwie ab. Und dann ist das Aluminium wieder in der Erde. Oder wird es dabei chemisch zersetzt, dass es gar kein Aluminium mehr ist?
Es wird mit der Atmosphäre reagieren zu verschiedenen Verbrennungsprodukten. Das, was an einzelnen kleinen Partikelchen abreißt, wird gegebenenfalls auf den Boden landen, aber dann mit kinetischen Energien, die nicht kritisch sind. Gut, wir haben wöchentlich wieder Eintrittsereignisse von einzelnen Objekten, von diesen 16.000 Themen. Aber es sind nur so 10 pro Jahr, von denen wirklich unten am Boden irgendwas übrig bleibt. Es ist bisher noch kein Mensch zu Schaden gekommen. Trotzdem ist die Gefahr da. Und wie gesagt, wir steuern gegen, sobald sich bei einer geplanten Mission ergibt, dass das Risiko für eine Verletzung von einer oder mehr Personen 1 zu 10.000 oder mehr ist.
Und die Objekte, die man jetzt im Rahmen der Vermeidungsstrategie jetzt so oft diese 550 Kilometer runterfahren würde von 800, damit die dann sozusagen innerhalb von 25 Jahren eintauchen, das ist dann sozusagen so eine schleichende Verbrennung oder gibt es dann irgendwann so einen Tipping-Point, wo es sich dann einfach nicht mehr halten kann, die dann plumpst er sofort runter?
Also das Wiedereintrittsereignis sieht eigentlich für einen unkontrollierten Wiedereintritt wie von 550 Kilometer und einem Kontrollierten sieht eigentlich gleich aus. Der Effekt, wo es wirklich zu einer Verbrennung kommt und wo es zum Aufbrechen und zur Zertrümmung des Objekts kommt, spielt sich erst in 70 Kilometer Höhe ab. Das ist so einige Minuten vor dem Auftreffen auf der Erdoberfläche. Das heißt, die ganzen 25 Jahre, in denen sich das Objekt von 550 Kilometer runterschraubt, passiert fast nichts in Richtung Aufheizung. Erst mit dem allerletzten Umlauf, ein Umlauf dauert so 90 Minuten, da geht das ganz schnell. Da steigt das Objekt von ungefähr 90 Kilometern, das ist die größte Höhe, wo es noch eine geschlossene Bahn fliegen kann. Steigt das mehr oder weniger in einem Bogen ab, und das Ganze dauert dann so 30 Minuten. Und sobald die 70 Kilometer erreicht werden, fangen diese Prozesse an. Für einen Beobachter von außen würde es genauso aussehen.
Dann kulminiert sich das sozusagen. Es ist einfach so ein langer Anlauf, aber es ist dann genauso sofortig, wie das auch bei einer kontrollierten Absturzgeschichte der Fall wäre.
Ja, richtig.
Trotz alledem, ich meine, man kann jetzt so viel vermeiden und abstürzen lassen, wie man will. Es macht ja so den Eindruck, dass jetzt bei diesen Millionen von Kleinstobjekten und mindestens hunderttausenden von größeren Sachen und Fußballen und was da oben nicht noch alles so rumfliegt, das wird einfach voll da. Da ist irgendwie ganz schön was los. Und irgendwann hat der Kessler dann wahrscheinlich recht und nichts geht mehr. Muss man dann nicht mal die Müllabfuhr hinschicken? Ist das überhaupt möglich?
Also es hat sich tatsächlich gezeigt, seit ungefähr drei bis vier Jahren weiß man, dass selbst eine strenge Umsetzung aller Vermeidungsstrategien, wie sie auf den Tisch legen, das heißt, Entfernen der Objekte nach 25 Jahren, Vermeidung von Explosionen durch Passivierung, Kollisionsvermeidung nicht ausreichen, um das Ansteigen 800 Kilometer Höhe zu verhindern. Das heißt, der Kessler hat recht, in 800 Kilometer läuft es bereits so am Schnürchen, wie er sich das gedacht hat. Leider. Die einzige Möglichkeit, dem noch herzuwerden, ist, aktiv hinzufliegen und große, massive Flächen, also ausgediente Objekte, die besonders groß und massiv sind, rauszunehmen. Das Ziel muss einfach sein, die schlimmsten Kandidaten für eine Kollision rechtzeitig zu entfernen, bevor es zu einer Kollision kommt. Es macht keinen Sinn, diese ganzen vielen kleinen, möglichen Impaktoren zu entfernen. Davon gibt es einfach zu viele und das ist zu schwierig. Sondern man muss die Ziele sozusagen rausnehmen und die Masse rausnehmen. Nur so kann man ansteigen, darf er verhindern. Das ist natürlich traurig, denn das bedeutet letztendlich, dass man eine ganz so teure Mission planen muss, die nichts anderes zum Ziel hat, als ein anderes totes Objekt zu greifen, an sich zu ziehen, mit ihm gemeinsam zurück in die Atmosphäre zu verschwinden. Und dafür einige Millionen auszugeben, ohne weiteren Nutzen zu erreichen. Aber so weit sind wir heute, dass man über so was nachdenken muss.
Ließe sich das nicht irgendwie so drehen, dass man jetzt zwar einen neuen Satelliten aussetzt, aber dann so mit der Oberstufe nochmal sich einen anderen schnappt und den dann noch mit zurückschickt?
Idealerweise ja.
Man darf nur noch einen hochbringen, wenn man einen anderen wieder mit runterholt.
Ja, es ist so wie das Pfandflaschen-System. Man muss über so was nachdenken. Die Frage ist, wie bringt man den Satellitentreiber dazu? Man kann ihm das nicht vorschreiben. Man muss dazu kommen, dass man das kann. Bedingungen muss auch meiner Meinung nach sein...
Man könnte ihn belohnen, dann würde es ja Geld geben.
Das würde gehen, ja. Das ist übrigens das, wo man sich jetzt zurzeit kreativ austoben kann. Was gibt es sozusagen für finanzielle Mechanismen, sowas in Gang zu kriegen? Einer hat mal vorgeschlagen, dass jeder quasi so eine Art Deposit abgeben muss in einen gemeinsamen Pool, bevor er startet. Und wenn er dann die Vermeidungsstrategien nicht ordnungsgemäß umsetzt, dann kriegt er das nicht wieder. Wenn ja, kriegt er nach Ende der Mission das Geld zurück. Und das gesammelte Geld, was nicht zurückgegeben wird, kann dann verwendet werden, um solche Missionen durchzuführen. Das klingt alles ganz gut, aber wie kriegt man das implementiert? Ohne ein starkes Weltraumrecht im Rücken.
Das heißt, eigentlich muss das schon das Ziel sein, dass man irgendwann mal so auf UNO-Ebene oder einer internationalen Verständigung sich darauf einigt. Wer daran teilnehmen will, muss sich einfach an diese Vermeidungsstrategien oder an dieses Pfandsystem gewöhnen.
Mit Einklinken, genau. Wir werben dafür. Wir sprechen auch selber bei den Vereinten Nationen vor. Es gibt da auch einen Ausschuss für technische Fragen. Der Weltraum-relevante Ausschuss ist UNCOPUS, hat den lustigen Namen United Nations Committee on the Peaceful Uses of Outer Space. Das ist unser Gremium. Wir werden nicht müde, da solche Sachen aufzutischen. Aber man muss natürlich auch die technische Machbarkeit angucken. Hier haben auch die Deutschen das DLR die Nase vorn. Denn bei der Umsetzung von solchen, wir nennen das Retrieval-Missionen oder Environment Remediation Actions, da ist das DLR gerade dabei, eine Demonstrator-Studie durchzuführen. Das heißt, einen kleinen Satelliten zu starten. Er nennt sich DEOS. Dieser DEOS-Satellit bringt seinen eigenen Klienten mit. Das Objekt, das er greifen will und herunterbringen will. Für diese Demonstrator-Phase benutzt er ein Objekt, das er selber beim Start mitbringt. Das ist etwas genau Bekanntes, von dem man auch eine bestimmte Rotation aufprägen kann. Dass man verschiedene Schwierigkeitsgrade des Greifens, des Annäherns und des Dockens ausprobieren kann. Das wird da getestet und ausprobiert. Das DLR ist traditionell auf dem Gebiet Robotik stark. München-Lamboltzhausen gibt es auch eine Versuchsanlage. Das ist ein vielversprechender Ansatz.
In Lampoltzhausen oder Oberpfaffenhof?
Oberpfaffenhof, Entschuldigung.
München-Oberpfaffenhof.
Professor Landzettel. Wenn alles gut geht in einigen Jahren, sehen wir, dass zum ersten Mal ein Satellit ein anderes Objekt greift, an sich zieht und dann kontrolliert, also kontrolliert, mit Null Risiko auf dem Boden zum Wiedereintritt bringt.
Aber wäre es nicht auch vorstellbar, kann man da nicht gerade so diese Kleinsteile, kann man denen nicht irgendwie anders beikommen mit, weiß nicht, Laserstrahlen, das hab ich mal bei James Bond gesehen, keine Ahnung, so einen Satelliten hochschickt, der einfach nur um sich herum schaut, ob irgendwas angeflogen kommt und sich davon gar nicht traktieren lässt oder das Ding einfach wegdampft. Bevor es irgendwie einschlägt und sozusagen alles eliminiert, was an ihm vorbeikommt. So eine Art permanenter Staubsauger.
Klingt gut, aber vom Satelliten aus ist es sicherlich schwer. Aber es gibt tatsächlich Überlegungen, sowas vom Boden aus zu machen. Dass man sagt, es geht natürlich nur mit Objekten, die man kennt, aber wenn sie eine bestimmte Größe haben, da könnte man sie zielgenau mit dem Laser ansteuern. Man wird es vielleicht nicht schaffen, die komplett zu verdampfen, aber man könnte vielleicht einen Punkt auf der Oberfläche aufheizen. Und wenn der anfängt zu brodeln und zu gasen und sozusagen Partikel und Gas wegstößt in eine Richtung, dann gibt dem das einen Impuls. Und dieser Impuls, den kann man so ausrichten, dass er letztendlich eine Abrämsung bewirkt. Und dazu führt, dass das Objekt langsam herunterkreiselt auf so einer Spiralbahn, wenn man es oft genug bestrahlt. Das ist, denke ich, eine Einsatzmöglichkeit für einen Leser, die dieser Vision schon so ein bisschen nahe kommt, trotzdem machbar ist.
Vom Satelliten aus ist es schwierig, wegen der Energie, die man benötigt?
Ja, auch die Zeit, die man hat. Wir sehen, in den allermeisten Fällen kommt das Objekt von vorne. Das hängt mit der Geometrie der Bahn ab, mit dem wir es zu tun haben. Das heißt, es kommt mit 14 km pro Sekunde auf einen zu. Das heißt, man wird es nie sehen.
Man merkt es erst, wenn es zu spät ist.
Ja, wenn man sich die Distanz von 14 km auf der Erde vorstellt. Dann eine Sekunde. Das heißt, man hätte drei Sekunden zwischen Darmstadt und Frankfurt, das Objekt zurückzulegen und da noch einen Laser auszurichten, um irgendwas zu bewirken. Da hat man keine Chancen.
Klangt gut, die Idee.
Es gibt interessanterweise auch immer wieder, es gibt auch Astronauten an Bord der Internationalen Raumstation. Die ist natürlich auch nicht verschont vor solchen Sachen. Man muss regelmäßig Ausweichmanöver fliegen. Neuen gab es schon. In allen Fällen behauptet ein Astronauten steif und fest, er hätte das Objekt gesehen. Aber es ist schwer, sie von dem Gegenteil zu überzeugen. Denn die Beleuchtungsverhältnisse sind selten so, dass man es lange sieht. Diese paar Mikrosekunden, denen es wirklich in Sichtweite ist...
Das ist wahrscheinlich die moderne Form von Seemannsgarn.
Ja, genau. So wird es wahrscheinlich sein.
Und was gibt es noch für verrückte Ideen? Kann man da nicht sowieso Fischernetzen irgendwie... Ja, also Gelnetzen, alles so einfangen.
Eine sehr anleuchtende Sache ist natürlich, nehmen wir mal als Betreiber eines Satelliten auf der gelstationären Bahn. Das, was die Betriebsdauer normalerweise limitiert, ist der Treibstoffvorrat. Den brauche ich dazu, um den Satelliten auf seiner Position zu halten. Wenn der alles, können vielleicht alle Geräte, Transponder, Solarzellen eigentlich noch voll intakt sein. Aber wenn der Treibstoff alle ist, ist die Mission vorbei. Wäre doch elegant, wenn man eine sozusagen Servicer-Mission hätte, die undockt und das Objekt wieder auftankt. Sodass man die vorhandene Masse im All und die ganzen funktionsfähigen Subkomponenten einfach weiter nutzen kann, indem man einen neuen Treibstoff nachliefert. Wenn der Satellit aufgetankt ist, fliegt der Servicer weiter zum nächsten und tut das Gleiche. Stellt damit auch gleichzeitig sicher, dass genug Treibstoffvorrat da ist, um letztendlich, wenn es mal wirklich zu Ende geht, den Satelliten hinaus zu hieven auf die Friedhofsbahn. Er fordert natürlich sozusagen die entsprechende Schnittstelle auf dem Satelliten, dass er sozusagen Tankstutzen hat, der es natürlich heute noch nicht gibt. Aber man könnte vielleicht zukünftige Missionen von vornherein so auslegen. Wenn es dann mal ein Satelliten erwischt hat, und der ist nicht mehr kontrollierbar, und man hat die Kontrolle verloren und er trudelt durch den gestationären Ring, da muss man sich überlegen, wie man den greift. Diese Dinger, da macht man sich häufig keine Vorstellungen, sind gewaltig groß, teilweise bis zu 40 Meter Spannbreite, wenn die Solarzellen komplett ausgefahren sind. Häufig gehen die verschiedensten Spinnenbewegungen über, wenn sie einmal unkontrolliert sind. Wie kommt man da ran? Hat der Satellit irgendein standardisiertes Bauteil, auf dem man so einen Greifer auslegen könnte? Leider hat kein Satellit den Griff zum Wegschmeißen. Was viele Satelliten gemeinsam haben, ist eine kleine Düse hinten, mit der sich der Satellit irgendwann mal auf die Bahn selber eingeschossen hat. Das ist dann vielleicht standardisiert genug, um da einen Greifer zu entwickeln, um den Satellit regelmäßig reinzugreifen. Wenn das nicht geht, dann muss man über solche Sachen mit dem Netz nachdenken. Einige sprechen auch von einer Hapune, in der man den Satellit aufschließt. Das kommt natürlich mit verschiedenen Problemen, denn die Hapune macht vielleicht auch viel kaputt und teile Platzen ab. Und mit denen hat man es dann wieder zu tun.
Nichts ist ideal.
Gutes sind immer die Sachen, die man von vorne rein vorsieht. Ein standardisiertes Greiferschnittstille, ein Tankstutzen, alles, was zukunftsweisend ist im Hinblick auf solche Servicing-Missionen. Wäre ideal.
Aber ist es offensichtlich, es muss was getan werden?
Oh ja.
Und da kann man auch noch eine ganze Menge Kreativität entfalten.
Ja, du siehst, ich bin schlecht ausgeschlafen. Aus diesem Grund. Nein, ganz so schlimm ist es nicht. Aber wir haben allein schon durch das Alltagsgeschäft mit der Kollisionsvermeidung macht uns jeden Tag deutlich, dass das ein Fulltime-Job ist. Und die Belastung dadurch wird noch größer werden. Das, was an Kosten und für solche Maßnahmen, die wir gerade angesprochen haben, noch oben draufkommt, belastet die Raumfahrtindustrie. Und belastet die Raumfahrt selber, macht auch die Services irgendwann teuer, die vom Weltraum kommen. Es muss einfach, und das entwickelt sich langsam, das Bewusstsein, wachsen, dass man sich letztendlich selber ins Bein schießt. Wenn man die Raumfahrt auf die Art und Weise belastet, macht man sie teurer. Wir wollen Raumfahrt betreiben. Unser Ziel ist es, Raumfahrt zu betreiben. Deswegen machen wir diese Arbeit. Und dazu sind einige Maßnahmen heutzutage einfach notwendig.
Vielleicht zum Ende. Wie viel arbeiten denn in diesem Space-Debris-Office an dieser ganzen Problematik?
Wir sind vier Leute. Zwei beschäftigen sich mehr oder weniger fulltime mit der Kollisionsvermeidung von ESA-Satelliten operationell. Die anderen beiden beschäftigen sich mit den Vermeidungsstrategien und der Implementierung dieser Vermeidungsstrategien in den neuen ESA-Missionen. Und auch unterstützen die Entwicklung des SSA-Programms, also des Space-Surveillance-Systems für Europa.
Und was sind das so für, sind das auch alles Ingenieure?
Wir haben drei Ingenieure und einen Mathematiker. Der ist aber trotzdem ganz nett.
Ich freu mich gerade, welche Fähigkeiten man sozusagen mitbringen muss, um sozusagen in dem Bereich aktiv zu werden. Das ist ja gar nicht so sehr eine Ingenieurstätigkeit. Deswegen wundert mich jetzt, ich hätte fast mehr Mathematiker oder vielleicht auch Physiker erwartet.
Man trifft in dem Bereich eigentlich homogen Physiker, Mathematiker, Ingenieure, Ingenieure, dann Luft- und Raumfahrtechniker im Wesentlichen. Alle sind von ihrer Ausbildung auf physikalische Grundprinzipien geeicht, auf denen die Orbit-Dynamik beruht. Und das ist das Wesentliche. Man muss sich gut auskennen mit der Dynamik von Objekten im Weltall. Wie bewegt sich ein Objekt, welchen Störeinflüssen unterliegt es? Das Interessante bei der Weltraum-Schrott-Problematik ist, die Objekte sind tot, in der Regel. Und unterliegen damit eigentlich nur den Störkräften der Natur und keinen anderen Einflüssen. Das heißt, die ganze Theorie, die man im Studium gelernt hat für die Orbit-Mechanik und Orbit-Dynamik, die kommt da zum Tragen und lässt sich wunderbar umsetzen. Alle, die sich damit befasst haben, sind in dem Bereich gut aufgehoben. Es ist trotzdem sehr multidisziplinär, denn wenn es in Richtung Wiedereintritt kommt, dann muss man auch über Satelliten-Erodynamik, Aerothermik und so weiter nachdenken. Dann muss man auch dort Expertise haben. Wenn es um Schutzkonzepte geht, das heißt Schilde, muss man sich mit Hochgeschwindigkeitsdynamik auskennen. Wenn man Kenntnisse über die Atmosphäre hat, ist das vorteilhaft, weil es immer wieder Rollenspiele hat. Wenn man natürlich mit der Raumfahrzeugentwicklung befasst ist, das heißt, in welcher Stufe der Entwicklung muss man welche Maßnahmen beachten. Wann wird es teuer, wenn man eine Maßnahme zu spät einführt? Wann muss man welchen Schritt am besten durchführen? Das ist dann, wo das Ingenieursmäßige zum Tragen kommt. Das heißt, jeder findet in diesem multidisziplinären Raum eine Nische, wenn er solange einen naturwissenschaftlichen Hintergrund hat.
Dass man irgendwann mal speziell so Weltraummüllwerke ausbildet, ist auch nicht ganz so wahrscheinlich.
Ja, könnte sein, dass es auch mal Lehrfach wird. Es gibt an der TU Braunschweig bereits eine Vorlesung zu dem Thema Raumfahrtrückstände.
Genau, die Uni, die sich darauf spezialisiert hat.
Es ist im akademischen Bereich schon verankert. Die Leute, die daherkommen, nennen sich nicht Weltraumschrott-Spezialisten, aber sie haben zumindest schon mal was davon gehört und kennen sich damit aus.
Ja, haben wir irgendwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ja, ich hab jetzt auch nichts mehr hier auf meiner Notizliste. Dann sag ich schon mal danke für den Einblick in den Bereich, der einem so ein bisschen auch die Haare zu Berge stehen lassen kann, wenn man sich mal so überlegt, wie das da alles um zusammenhängt. Aber trotzdem spannender Einblick. Ja, vielen Dank Holger. Und das war's hier, unsere siebte Ausgabe zum Bereich Weltraumrückstände. Klingt aber nicht so poppig, oder?
Ja, uns rutscht auch an Dauernd Weltraum Schrott raus. Sind wir mal ehrlich.
Ja, ich finde auch Schrott klingt dann auch so ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, Schrott hat auch so was Lebendiges. Wenn man selber mal über so einen Schrottplatz gelaufen ist, da sieht man dann ja auch wirklich die Historie und Geschichte und jeden Unfall, man kann irgendwie alles ablesen. Ich glaube, das ist dann immer noch das Spannendste daran. Ja, gut und an alle Hörer, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Hier geht es bald weiter mit der achten Ausgabe. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.